let's examine
how well they're pretty some of their
predictions about Sweden uh held up and
one kind of the the premier example
really is this Imperial College of
London model which that was the you know
Neil Ferguson's operation that project
this these were the projections that
policy makers around the world were
using to determine what kind of policy
to implement and what they predicted for
Sweden I just pulled uh some of the
numbers from their uh projections uh and
again as always our sources are linked
in the description of the video and at
reason.com but in green here these are
this is their range of predictions if
Sweden's social distance the whole
population
using Amanda using a lockdown strategy
the total desks they projected between
about thirty thousand and forty two
thousand in red this is the unmitigated
strategy this is you know if Sweden
doesn't do lockdowns which is the policy
they they pursued they're projecting
between 66
000 and 90 000 deaths in Sweden the
reality here I pulled from the who's
covid-19 dashboard by the way this
projection was for July 1st so deaths by
July 1st 2020
deaths by July 2nd 2020 were 14
633 so
about half of the projection with a
mitigation strategy uh and then you know
the total death rate was you know uh I
think not even 30 000 at the end of the
day from from covid-19
continuing through like putting uh
Sweden in the context of other countries
this is from your policy paper or a
slide that I pulled you on we see
Sweden's coveted death rate is pretty
much in the middle of the pack when you
take all of Europe and the us into
accounts with uh
2322 deaths per million
um and then this was a the really
striking one you'll see Sweden at the
very bottom of this chart because
Sweden's excess death rate during the
pandemic was the lowest in Europe
what do we what do we take from this
fact right here
um why why do we have any theories as to
why Sweden actually had fewer excess
deaths than the rest of the continent
yeah this is a shocker uh that those
numbers and it tells you first of all I
think that don't put too much trust in
models like that because they can't
really make a serious forecast because
it was all based on just two options
um shutting down Societies or just
business as usual and everybody lives
exactly like they did before the
pandemic they didn't have room for
people actually on a voluntary basis
doing things like working from home
trying to avoid public transportation if
they could and and so on so that's
obviously a major factor Behind These
this data and then when it comes to
Total excess deaths over the three
pandemic years compared to the three
previous years the fact that Sweden
actually had the lowest accrued excess
death rate in Europe and less than half
of America's uh that comes as a surprise
to most people and let me just say that
you can adjust those numbers in
different ways according to the years
you compare it to age structure Health
structure in the population According to
some ways of doing this Denmark beats us
to first place but we're
almost the lowest excess death rates
much lower than countries like Finland
for example who seem to be doing better
during the pandemic so it tells you that
it's not necessarily this dramatic
trade-off between Liberty and health
I do think one other thing that we
should throw in there because Zach and I
were doing some research on this in
preparing for this
um but the you know median age given
that we know that covet is especially um
you know higher mortality for the
elderly versus uh the young uh one thing
we are interested in is okay could one
explanation be that you know countries
with higher excess mortality rates just
had really really old populations and
countries that were more successful are
just young healthy spry
um but in reality I mean the median age
uh in a lot of parts of Scandinavia
Sweden included uh and the United States
it's all roughly comparable and so
that's not a variable that is
um significantly different to some
degree you know I think U.S median age
is something like 38 and I believe it's
the same in Sweden maybe like 39 and so
that is uh commonality
um that I think it's important like to
some degree we have sort of controlled
for that variable in uh assessing this
um I do want to ask though so it's
explain more of the political culture
and some of the characteristics of
Sweden that led to
um you know this really really high
success like to some degree I almost
want to try to learn from this voluntary
model uh it does also seem although I
like your analysis which is blame Italy
a little bit uh for the spread of the
coronavirus in Sweden which I'm totally
on board with blaming Italians as much
as possible
there is an interesting thing that you
know we should talk about which is that
the virus came to Stockholm very very
early on and so tell me about that
experience where coronavirus was
coursing through Sweden but to some
degree maybe that led to Greater herd
immunity earlier on before the vaccine
was developed could you explain that to
us yeah that's right we got it early
February and at full disclosure I was on
a flight from Austria that week as well
a family vacation and I got a call from
a doctor at One hospital who asked me so
were you on that plane on this seat in
this seat uh yes I was okay in that case
you'd better check your health because
you I apparently sat next to someone who
had the um the virus so it appeared I
didn't get it at that moment in time but
many people did that early on and I
think it had two effects yes probably
probably as more people were affected at
an early age and at an early stage and
obviously that can help later on to
create some sense of some sort of
immunity against it but also that that
it seemed like it was already too late
to do anything about it the virus was
already here whereas some other
countries like Norway and Denmark
thought that okay it might be heading
our way let's just shut everything down
for a month or or so and that's why it
seemed like Sweden was doing so much
worse
early on uh than than others
and then there are other aspects of
Swedish political culture if you want me
to go into that but well yeah I think we
do want to go into that um and I've got
a good there there was another clip of
uh Anders 10 yelled I think uh will
Broach that topic because Liz and I were
watching this and it just struck us sort
of he's talking about herd immunity
which we just discussed a little bit and
his tone in discussing Sweden's policy
approach his humility was kind of
interesting and uh a contrast to what we
often experience here so let's run that
uh other tenure clip atom
can you regard a situation in which your
country has getting on for 30 000
infections of covid-19 in the population
has a death toll which is significantly
higher than your neighbors standing at
around three and a half thousand can you
regard that as success or do you have to
acknowledge that in some ways your
strategy failed yeah no ma'am that's
true when it comes to the death toll
this didn't work out the way we hoped it
on the other end I mean the connection
between our basic strategy and slowing
down the spread if that's really in the
long run will affect the total death
toll in a society or not that is not
clear yet I mean we know that our
neighboring countries by now have around
one percent of the population
who had some kind of immunity has had
disease we have at least 10 maybe 20
times higher level of immunity in the
population you're inviting me there to
consider the long-term significance of
this notion this concept of herd
immunity now your own government says
that the strategy that you implemented
the more moderate the the the the less
strict uh emergency response to covid-19
was not about establishing herd immunity
but you seem to be suggesting that
actually it is about getting to that
point where so many people in the
general population have had covid-19 and
therefore we can assume have some
resistance to getting it again that you
have this concept of herd immunity in
your population it was that the working
strategy or not no it was not I'm just
pointing out one way that shows that you
cannot make this kind of easy
comparisons at this stage because the
epidemic has hit different countries in
many different ways
so this strikes me as pretty humble
pretty measured and
um like he's actually being honest with
people and allowing them to assess uh
what they think of this strategy on
their own given the data as well as
being pretty clear about the time frames
that we're measuring this is a stark
contrast to what we've seen from Anthony
fauci in the United States explain these
deeper differences in political culture
and how this leads to trust or distrust
in institutions
um
this is very interesting because I think
that here Sweden is the outlier and it's
partly a result of the kind of division
of uh powers that exist in government
and in government in Sweden so a person
like tangel and the public health
authority in Sweden is not as
politicized as they are in other places
it's not like the President appoints his
sort of top health expert and then he's
supposed to sort of be almost a
politician
having an agenda and defending it
whatever happens to to data and whatever
happens to the world
those Health authorities other
government agencies in Sweden are
supposed for hundreds of years to be
fairly independent now that's not always
a good thing but it might be in certain
instances because it often means that
they don't have to play politics so the
boss of a an agency is appointed by the
government but on a longer mandate he's
not replaced when there's a new
government in town a new prime minister
which means that they're supposed to be
less about a political agenda more about
following the law and following the data
wherever it goes and that this means
that technol doesn't have to defend any
particular ideology or a political
program or anything like that he tells
you what he thinks the reading of the
science is and then the government is of
course free to follow that advice or
reject it but by tradition they usually
come pretty close and I my suspicion is
that one reason is that if everything
fails they can blame techno for it
whereas that would be much more
difficult in a system where they
directly they're they're part of of the
government hey thanks for watching that
clip from our conversation with Johann
Norberg about Sweden's pandemic policies
you can watch the full conversation
right here or another clip from that
conversation right over here